Jaypee I'll be ready
so Comedy Central has screwed me again
it gave me another boring white guy to
roast I had to google him Google told me
to go to Bing Bing told me to go to ask
Jesus jesus said I don't know who this
nigger is it's pretty good first of all
just I want to say what an honor it is
for me to be here with some icons of
comedy I mean Jay Pharoah Jim Norton
Cedric the Entertainer there are a lot
of great comics in New York but truly
yamaneika really is one of the loudest
JP is a Catholic Wall Street banker the
only thing whiter and slimy er than him
is to come on his back from father
O'Brien I knew this is gonna be a tough
battle because like we look like we're
on opposite ends of the fire hose let me
just say no yamaneika is so dark she got
cast in 12 years of slave as the plot JP
is from Newtown Connecticut where the
Sandy Hook tragedy happened and the
worst thing that happened that town and
that he wasn't seven years old at the
time that shooter
[Applause]
gotcha okay okay thank you fat thighs
matter
[Applause]
yamaneika grew up in a white suburban
town in Maryland her nickname in high
school was huh keep it go with JP big
day so much fun super close I had to say
it both really great uh yummy Niigata
great that Sandy Hook joke was brutal
and really great and some you you great
firing back but JP I thought the the
hose joke was it was brilliant I had to
go with JP you're kind of creepy in
suburban but you're really funny
thank you thank you this is exciting
this is like watching Leslie Jones take
on one of her internet trolls
[Applause]
you both were amazing but I
gotta give it to JP on the cleverness
the jokes were amazing JP just a
picture he just surprised me because I
thought yamaneika won this thing when
she said got your ass and spun around I
thought it was pretty much over my boat
spur yamaneika I honestly loved both of
you I have to tell you he's like a
Jaisal Nick in that he's that sharp and
mean and nasty but you like him anyway
now her bitch and I have to vote for ID
you're both this is by a air I have
to give it to you the black girl
I forgot your name how many girls open
yourself something normal like a
white person so I say both for the black
chick come on clap it up her she was
good we're turn-up
it all comes down to you X SNL cast
member Jay Pharoah it got daggit okay I
got a TD but okay I would have to
say don't get mad at me baby oh man
yamaneika bow I would say see look at
the seed y'all you see
yamaneika I would say I'm gonna keep
battling yamaneika until I win I'm just
gonna try to exact revenge for the rest
of my life this affection that you see
right here at least on my part 100%
intact not real at all ladies use mine
I'm gonna eat him help please be some
help
ah
[Applause]